let's start spring off with a boom bang
we a chef and owner of boom bank fine
foods and cocktails here to give us a
sneak peek of their new spring menu how
are you i am doing great so excited to
be here yes ready for spring ready for
the weather to chase i mean new flavors
to eat as well but first and foremost i
have to ask you yes so where does the
inspiration come from behind boom bang
what does that mean well it's a long
story but really what it is is get it
done let's go i like that
so when you're done finishing or cooking
a meal you're like boom bang there it is
boom bang eat it and enjoy
i like that energy okay let's talk about
the spring menu what can we expect so i
mean it's we're adding a lot of
beautiful vegetables we're trying to
stay as local as possible you know now
people are growing stuff here in vegas
there's a beautiful farmer's market in
henderson
so we're trying to buy as much from the
people in the farmers market we have
really good relationships with them now
so it's really nice it's cool it's fresh
like this watercress and our beautiful
new
spring chicken has like zatar i'm
mexican but i'm lebanese as well so
there's satire and roasted potatoes
there's like a creme fraiche sauce
underneath with a lot of garlic of
course the fresh watercress
and uh we're doing like pear soup
uh fresh first let's taste the pear soup
of course i'm gonna make you one right
okay oh yes perfect so it has like
scallops and toasted pecans with fresh
chive oil oh my goodness um yeah so and
then we have also for vegetarians you
know we have this like cauliflower steak
with beautiful beets and lettuces and
like this potato puree on top that's
purple but
it's interesting you guys need to come
and try it and honestly i just had a
potato yes and if your potatoes taste
like that
i need the whole menu it's all made me
cook
boom baby
yeah so the pear soup is like fresh
pears that i poached in this uh syrup
with different condiments like um
anise
and allspice and then they get cooked
with broth and cream and reduced for a
long time okay then i like grind them
and then make a really nice puree and
then they get topped with um toasted
pecans
which is really nice and then um
chive oil do you wanna yes i would love
to do the honors just drizzle it yeah
around boom bang it
yes
yes
and then we make this puff pastry twist
with zatar again and then we sears the
uh scallops
and then it gets just cut in half
and uh it gets placed on top of the
little crouton like boom bang like boom
bang so as you finish that let's talk
can we talk about briefly you know what
else the menu has in store just besides
the spring menu yes i mean we have our
pork chang that's basically like my
signature dish some favorites right yes
it's braised for
like 16 hours you know and it's it comes
with a romaine salad
uh no ramen salad i roasted romaine and
crumble and then we have a delicious
mushroom tart with goat cheese mousse uh
short rib i mean who doesn't look like a
short rib but you can overnight mostly
you just need to come by and try it
right yes and we do brunch
and with speaking of brunch you have a
beautiful patio set too
yes beautiful patio setup a brand new uh
furniture in it a lounge brand new
garden
going and our cocktails are wonderful
too you need to come you know our
website is uh boombang dot restaurant
and we're right over 2 15 and buy a
verde and we're ready for you
this is so delicious yes oh my gosh boom
bang okay booming yes you guys have to
go visit i'm going to come by you should
yeah i want to do this i want to do the
patio for sure yes absolutely thank you
thank you so much so there's more las
vegas now coming up